hello friends this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show this is by far the most
difficult podcast intro that I've ever
recorded I've already tried to do it six
or seven times and have failed so I'm
just gonna run with it and the reason
for the difficulty will become super
clear quickly the guest is Terry Lachlan
who completely changed my life he became
friend a mentor he taught me how to swim
and did it remotely at first through his
book total immersion when I was in my
30s and fixing that helped me to address
one of my lifelong largest insecurities
and something that really caused a lot
of humiliation frame which was growing
up on Long Island being close to water
having a few traumatic experiences and
never learning to swim until my 30s and
Terry you can learn all about Total
Immersion everywhere
just search total immersion swimming
total immersion net Ti swim on Twitter
etc is really a revolutionary way of
learning and teaching and he was
introduced to me or the method total
immersion was introduced to me by Chris
Sacca who's another friend who's been on
the podcast billionaire investor
all-around
hilarious and intelligent guy who said
to me at a barbecue I have the answer to
your prayers as it related to not being
able to swim and it turned out to be
Terry Laughlin and Total Immersion the
reason this is so hard is that I grew to
really care for Terry and we did this
interview October 2nd
Terry had
at that time metastasized pancreatic
cancer that was October 2nd on October
10th he had a stroke and was
hospitalized and then on October 20th
ten days later he passed away I just
found out about this yesterday afternoon
after getting back from being off the
grid I turned on my phone and a barrage
of texts came in and the first one that
I saw was from a friend who said did you
see the news about Terry and that makes
this what you're about to hear the last
long-form interview the Terry ever did
in his life and it's intended to be
inspiring and to showcase a tactically
brilliant and sincere teacher he
developed 24 national champions but then
turned his eye to the adult population
people who had given up on themselves
who had accepted partial completeness
who thought that learning to swim or x
y&z whatever you might have in your mind
was impossible and taught them to
overcome that and I really view him as
the epitome of what I try to do myself
as a teacher whether it is looking at
accelerated learning or deconstructing
something logically sequencing it he
cares so [ __ ] much and that will come
across in this interview even if you
don't care about swimming at all I
encourage you to listen to this for a
few different reasons number one this is
like I said the last long firm interview
Terry did in his life and when you
listen to this you will hear that he
sounds incredibly vibrant and was what I
also did and I owe sincere thanks to his
family for sending this to me
this included audio at the end of the
interview and these are clips
that within the first few days after his
stroke in the hospital so a week before
he died or so his daughters Fiona
kerri-anne Betsy recorded audio
interviewed him following his stroke
because he was extremely focused the
entire time on the mission of finishing
his current book so they were asking him
questions and pulling out these
philosophies of life and so on in this
environment of hospitalized medicine
where you have beepers and you have
footsteps you have staff moving around
and I want you to listen to it because
it's [ __ ] heart-wrenching and I want
you to surrender yourself to that
sadness and to let it envelop you and to
really listen to it it's not intended to
impart a ton of super tactical
information it's intended to make you
feel just how painful it is to have time
running out and I want you to ask
yourselves because I've written five
books now and many people have changed
their lives by testing assumptions and
finally doing the things that they have
put off whether it's quitting something
starting something taking a trip forming
a company quitting a job ending a
relationship proposing to someone
whatever it might be I've seen that but
I've also seen thousands of people
sitting on the sidelines with the a
deferred life plan of some type
something that they are deferring to
some day when it's going to be more
convenient which it never will be
generally speaking there's never a good
time to do the things that are most
important and so I want you to listen
not only to the interview but to the
clips at the end they were recorded in
the hospital because I want you to
extremely acutely feel in your viscera
the reality which is we are not
guaranteed
a long life and I've had several friends
die in the last year I don't know what's
going around in the air but several
friends die in the last year young and
old and people do not die of old age
they die of disease they die of accident
they die from violence there are so many
things that you can take you out before
you think your lifespan will end
so hopefully this interview this
conversation with the incredible Terry
Laughlin can serve as a catalyst for you
to get up off your ass physically or
metaphorically speaking and do what it
is you really want to do so that you
don't die with a bucket list of things
that have not been checked off and that
certainly was not Terry Terry squeezed
every drop out of his life up until the
very very last moments and you get to
hear some of those moments so this is
really surreal for me and I miss him
already
so Terry thank you for changing my life
and I hope you're swimming far and wide
up in heaven and you know he he kept in
good spirits until the very very closing
bell and there's actually a piece and
outside magazine written by Christie
Wanda and I hope I'm getting the
pronunciation right who's a lead or the
lead science writer at 5:38
and she describes how at the very end
you know that the last time that his
daughter Fiona saw him laugh was him
telling this joke about baseball because
he loved baseball and he and the joke
related to two friends who had a pact
the first of them to die would return to
tell the other whether there was
baseball in heaven so the first guy dies
and he appears to his friends the good
news he says is that there's baseball in
heaven the bad news is
you're pitching tomorrow Terry thought
that was hilarious
and he was able to find the glimmers of
hope and optimism even when he was
literally on his deathbed
so for the things that you want to do
for the things you feel compelled to do
for the things that you've dreamed up
for so long what is your excuse for not
doing them think about it
very very carefully and meditate on it
because we're all gonna die it's just a
question when and in any case my
apologies for the long introduction this
has been really difficult for me and
this is the best job I can do with this
one guys so please enjoy this
wide-ranging conversation with none
other than the incredible much beloved
and much missed Terry Lachlan Terry
welcome to the show thank you for having
me on Tim I've really wanted to do this
for quite a while
well I've wanted to have you on for many
many years and I thought I would start
before we get into the backstory and
there's so many different things that we
should cover in this conversation but I
think the most sensible place for a lot
of my listeners is where I came in
contact with Total Immersion and I
should start by saying I grew up on Long
Island for those people who don't know I
and I was a townie out in East Hampton
of all places worked in the lobster
all's bus points on and I was minutes
from the beach
my whole life and never learned how to
swim properly until my 30s and the I
suppose the trigger for preventing me to
swim were a handful of near drowning
experiences one at a summer camp and
it's it was always one of my largest
sources of embarrassment and one of my
greatest insecurities and then something
happened and what happened was this was
several of course several years ago now
I just turned 40 but at the end of a
January I want to say in I'm not exactly
sure when it was 2007-2008 around there
a friend and I decided to issue each
other New Year's resolutions because we
realized that without someone to hold
you accountable very little tends to get
done with New Year's resolutions so
Chris Ashenden who's known as the Kiwi
because he's from New Zealand said that
I had to finish an open-water 1
kilometer race that was going to be in
2008 so it must have been the very
beginning 2008 and I then challenged him
to go a year without coffee or
stimulants because he fed himself
different types of stimulants to stay
awake and then did used booze to go to
sleep and so on it was very very normal
but I failed is the short story I at
least in the first say 1/2 or 3/4 of the
year tried kickboards barely moved at
all and it was extremely humiliating and
I had left a number of classes hand
paddles tried those my shoulders felt
like they were going to break which led
me to believe that swimming could not be
low-impact and I'd effectively conceded
defeat and then I met someone named
Chris Sacca for the first time who's
been on this podcast and he is now a
very very famous investor at the time he
was just starting his sort of ascension
his hockey stick and he was training for
a triathlon and we met at a barbecue
organized by a guy named Kevin Rose who
was the first episode of this podcast
and I told him about how I was failing
with swimming when he asked me what I
was up to I didn't start there but we
got there and he said I have the answer
to your prayers it revolutionized how as
how I how I
swim and that's that was his this was
opening sales pitch and that's what got
me to TI and Total Immersion and in the
span of I'd say around you know between
seven to ten days with a book this is
without even the video went from about a
like one to two lengths maximum and
swimming in a small kind of home pool
two more than forty lengths per workout
in sets of two to four and now fast
forward I swim for relaxation and part
of how I chose where I wanted to live
here where I'm recording in Austin Texas
was its proximity to swimming which just
is insane if you were to try to express
that to my I say fifteen year old self
twenty year old self even thirty year
old self so thank you that's a very
long-winded intro but I wanted to give
people the context because as Chris my
friend pointed out it's a it's a life
skill it's not just a throwaway
decorative skill and every time I was on
a boat I had low grant anxiety every
time I was near water or going into
water I had Lou Grant anxiety and I no
longer have that so thank you very
kindly sir that's certainly a most
gratified and let me just I'll bet I'll
bet you're familiar with deep Eddie pool
I am familiar with deep any pool just
down the road from the Magnolia cafe
which is run by your friends yeah and
and Barton Springs to two wonderful
places I love to swim when I visit
Austin then the fact that you can enjoy
them so is it that's that's the best
part it's not that you can swim 1k but
that you can take advantage of these
lovely swimming halls that are really
unique places and in a complete way and
and to do it as something that I enjoy I
mean it's something that I seek out and
I actually wanted to talk to you more
about a cup
the plans I have for swimming after this
podcast perhaps but the the punchline
also i didn't provide for people so i
improved my swimming and then i was not
able to find an open water race that was
one kilometer so instead i swam open
water in the ocean on Long Island on the
beach where I grew up going but really
going up to kind of my waist most of the
time and simply went offshore after
asking a lifeguard how far away a given
house was and swam parallel to shore in
the ocean which is pretty murky on that
side of things
pretty Sharky - and swam almost a mile
so that's a lot longer than one
kilometer and probably the most
successful I've ever felt in my entire
life and that is put you in really
rarefied company Tim I mean there are
not very many people who can swim a mile
in a pool but to swim a mile in an ocean
and it really really takes it up another
notch only only two percent there's a
pretty pretty authoritative estimate
that only 2% of American adults can swim
as much as a quarter-mile non-stop so
you're in rarefied company swim in a
mile in the ocean I've a lot of room to
improve but I think that the example of
swimming is one for me of a partial
completeness that I accepted and it was
an assumption ie I can't swim I don't
swim that I didn't test for a very very
long time and many people accept partial
completeness whether it's being say
overweight well that's just the way it
is that's just the way I am I'm good at
some things I'm just not able to lose
weight whatever it might be or in this
case say swimming or playing basketball
could be anything learning to read and I
wanted to ask you about just to give an
example of how late you can test these
some assumptions
Paul Laurie or Laurie I guess it is
Laurie Laurie yeah okay now you're Paul
alright can you explain for the people
listening who Paul Laurie is dr. polar e
Paul is a pretty amazing person to give
you an idea he retired from he was one
of the real pioneering pediatric
cardiologists in in the field of
medicine he was a giant in the field and
he retired from practice as a pediatric
cardiologist at age 68 and moved to
Albany from from Los Angeles and to be
close to his daughter and this is at age
68 and for the next 25 years
he was an emeritus professor at Albany
Medical College so he taught his final
seminar in pediatric cardiology at the
age of 93 which will give you an idea of
how unusual he is he moved to New Paltz
where I live into a senior living center
called woodland pond and it had a pool
it not only had a pool it had it had a
chorus it had a woodshop and Paul just
decided he was going to take complete
advantage of everything that they had
there and he had never been very serious
about swimming in his life so he ordered
one of our DVDs at age 93 and and taught
himself a pretty serviceable freestyle
and then at 94 he not happened to knock
on our door we have an Endless Pool in
our basement we call it the swim studio
and we teach we teach people from all
over the world and Alice answered the
door my wife Alice answered the door and
she said this this very slight man drew
himself up and says I'm dr. Paul Laurie
can someone here teach me an effortless
butterfly
so Alice told me about it and our
daughter Betsy was going to teach the
lesson so I showed up I had to watch
this and I saw a pulse one free sounds
pretty nice and then he tried a few
strokes a back stroke a butterfly excuse
me and after watching him swim for about
ten seconds I said Paul I think your net
your second stroke should be backstroke
and and I said I'll off I offered him
the ultimate senior discount I'll come
to the pool at woodland pond at no
charge
and teach you and I ended up teaching
him about three or four lessons and when
he was 95 we shot we shot a video of
Paul and I swimming together we were
doing what we call sink swimming where I
synchronized my stroke to his and I
posed the question on the video can you
tell which swimmer is 62 and which is 95
because we looked identical
just exactly alike and I was so proud of
him and to take this a little further
November November 18th I will be
attending his hundredth birthday party
and he's still swimming 20 lengths a day
Wow
yeah so it's never too late to start and
the thing that's such a wonderful I only
knew about 10% of that story I
definitely didn't know about me showing
up at the door
I'm dr. Paul Lori can you teach me he's
happy with those two strokes no I'll
tell you something else it's really
remarkable about Paul so he took his
first lesson at 94 he was still gaining
speed at 97 III don't know if there's
another example in physical capability
of someone improving proving between
1896 and 97 the way the way he timed it
was he swam at 20 length routine which
he continues to this day and in the 50
foot pool at at woodland party he does a
twenty-ninth routine where he swims
laughs and free and one of Beck until
he's done 20 lanes and his time for that
20 length routine improved in incredibly
in the first year so but it was still
getting faster between between age 96
and 97 in fact the day he went he
improved his time at 97 I got a I got a
text message from and his friend Marilyn
Bell who's another fantastic story over
and and she said Paul improved
I think his time I think he improved it
from 13 minutes and changed to 12 53
this morning and you know so I
immediately texted back to both of them
saying how how thrilled I was about that
and then Paul Paul texted me back and he
says yes I I went in with a plan to
improve my time now how many people are
going to the pool at age 97 with a plan
to a plan and a strategy to improve his
time and his his strategy was that he
was going to swim even more quietly than
before and you go faster by swimming
more quietly I mean it's just the the
whole unexpected nature of what he did
and the unexpected nature of his
strategy a very great cool story how did
you personally start swimming yes well
my dad started me when I was about 8 or
9 and my very first serious swimming
experience was was swimming at bar Beach
on Long Island now you were on the south
shore I was on the north shore
so in Hempstead Harbour on Long Island
Sound
Bar Beach and they had they had a raft
anchored I would guess maybe 30 feet
offshore ten yards or so and I used to
watch with with great Envy I used to
watch my dad swim out to the yacht to
the the raft and beyond and he would he
would come back and he would have me do
Deadman's flow
and move my arms in circles and and I
would sort of practice in the shallows
and then one day I just screwed up my
courage and decided I was gonna make a
try for that for the raft and I you know
swam as we all do when we take that
first swim in deep water which is
frantically and I got to the raft
gratefully pulled myself out and then
called a lifeguard to bring me back
escort me back safely as my mother tells
me so that was my start and then I a
pool opened we didn't have a pool at
that time in Williston Park where I grew
up and they opened a pool in 1963 when I
was 12 and I took the Red Cross swimmer
course and got my Red Cross swimmer
badge and joined the pool that the swim
team at the pool and then in eighth
grade at st. Aidan's school my Catholic
Grammar School I they announced a tryout
for the swimming team and there is not a
lower more grassroots level of swimming
than Catholic Diocese analysis and once
a once-a-year meet so they were going to
have a few practices and then swim in
the diocese an annual meet so I tried
out well I didn't even have to swim the
length of the pool it was the width of
the the Farmingdale Community College a
six-lane pool and when I when I got
across the pool there was a coach in
full clothing in the water next to me
who had jumped in jumped in to escort me
across not sure I would make it under my
own power so needless to say I didn't
make the cut not a fish and the guy who
cut me is still still alive friend of my
parents and and we still laugh about
that so but but then I they had the Red
Cross 50 mile swim chart at the pool as
all pools did in those days and you
could get a badge for swimming 50 miles
and I had 11 weeks in the summer to to
swim 50 miles so at age 13 I decided I
was going to earn that night I
discovered I really love this
solitude of doing laps and I I you know
just through doing the laps to earn the
50-mile badge which I did I turned
myself into an okay swimmer certainly
not one with any sort of a fishing
technique but but one who could could
swim a mile a day not many people can
and I I managed to turn myself into a
mile a day swimmer at age 13 so let's
let's flash forward and we can certainly
pick up anything in between but if we
look at say 1972
see you at that time my understanding is
begin coaching at the u.s. Merchant
Marine Academy correct and it was there
that you had an epiphany or sort of
observed something that would that would
later very much influence your teaching
style can you tell us about what what
you learned sure while you were catching
yeah this is it's it's such a it's it's
a foreshadowing and an unbelievable
foreshadowing of of how I would spend
the next 40 odd years you know first of
all to preface it I have to take note
that I had swum for eight years well
before I became a coach and I was I was
a very hardworking very frustrated
swimmer and during those eight years I
can remember one occasion when a coach
said anything to me about technique so I
got if you know if you take your cues
from what your coaches do they put
workouts on the board and then said
ready go and nobody said a word about
technique except for this one time where
that were the Cuddy one of my coaches
said Lachlan you'll never swim fast if
you don't move your arm slower that was
the only input because I was just I was
such a high turnover swimmer and I you
know as far as I knew how else do you
swim fast except by moving your arms
faster so so I'd gone through eight
years with not a word about technique
except at one time and then I was the
coach of the Merchant Marine Academy I
think I had 12 men in a 4-lane pool
and I gave them a garden-variety warm-up
of 800 yards of freestyle takes about 10
to 12 minutes to do and I watched them
from the end of the pool it's the first
time I'm ever watching swimmers and you
know we're Amon in the situation or the
responsibility of while being
responsible for their performance and I
must have been watching with a keener
eye than I ever had before because I
noticed that every swimmer in the pool
was asymmetrical those who breathe to
the left torqued and twisted in that
direction and those who breathe to the
right likewise and it just occurred to
me that you know if the object is to
move to the to the other end by
presumably by his laser line that it's
not good in every single stroke to be
diverting momentum and energy off to the
side so I went home that night pondering
what I'd what I'd seen and what I might
do about it and I decided that the next
more the next day for warm-up we were
gonna I was going to ask them since it
was related to their breathing I I gave
them 800 yards of freestyle but I said
I'd like you all to breathe on the wrong
side and because we all start our
swimming with a right side of us aside
on which we are naturally more
comfortable and the other side we don't
breathe to it because it feels more
awkward and uncomfortable so for the
next 10 to 12 minutes I had a markedly
more symmetrical team and I said that
can't be a bad thing I didn't know the
first thing about biomechanics at the
time it just seemed evident to me
aesthetically that anything that moved
you straight ahead was better than
something that kept averting you to the
side and I you know I was just so
gratified by the positive response to my
first seat-of-the-pants experiment in
stroke work that I thought I'm just
going to carry on and I did and it was
it was not difficult you know and I had
never been an assistant coach I had
never taken a coaching
or anything even remotely related to
sports science or swimming or
biomechanics or any of that
but I really trusted my aesthetic
judgment I trusted that what looked good
was good and I had I had an example of
that I had a four lane pool and there
was a hierarchy where the fast swimmers
were in lane one and the slow swimmers
were in lane four and as I cast my eye
across the pool the swimmers in lane one
the fast swimmers looked more taller in
the water they look longer as they
stroked and they were markedly smoother
and the swimmers in lane four were
shorter and more choppy and more rough
and I thought I'm just gonna experiment
with with them and try different things
to see if I can make them look more like
the swimmers in lane one and another
interesting thing happened when I
started engaging with them and as I said
the coaching I got was already go
coaching where the coach would give you
a set that lasted 30 minutes and then
just sit and watch you but when I was
when I was working with them on
technique I was engaging with them in a
much more intimate manner and I pretty
quickly noticed that there was another
difference between movement form between
quality of form and speed which was that
Kings Point was a little bit different
from a lot of colleges and that there
were no athletic scholarships and so
your reason for swimming came down to
you got as you got excused from
unwelcome unpleasant duties like like
cleaning out the latrine and marching
and reviews and stuff like that during
the during the length of the season or
or you really wanted to swim and I I saw
there was a big overlap between want to
swim and good form and faster swimming
in lane one and escapism and poor form
and and slow times in lane four so you
know then I it was a matter of how to
engage them as well and I found that
these you know these tech did the
technique challenges that I was
in the little puzzles to solve and so on
brought out in them a certain zest for
the workouts that had not been there
before so I'm really curious to know the
first where what would later become
Total Immersion kind of entered the
picture and I want to just make a couple
of footnotes because related to a number
of things you said for instance the
perhaps very in retrospect it's sensible
of his advice to for instance do what I
do now which is breathe every third
stroke which means I'm going right left
right left right left in a very
symmetrical way that's that's you know
what one of the points that you you
mentioned and then the the importance of
and this is something that I think
applies to just about everything and
just about not everything but just about
everything and that is when you get in
the pool and I remember this this had a
huge impact on me and I still have that
very initial Total Immersion book
somewhere it got wet a lot so it's not
in pristine condition but the idea that
you're say getting in the pool to
practice not to do a workout and at
least in the beginning the idea that if
it feels like a workout you're not doing
it correctly was really difficult for me
to first accept because I'm used or at
least at that point in physical training
I thought that your results were a
direct output from an input which was
effort right and it was a huge mental
shift for me to gauge my practice the
quality of the success of a practice
based on how little effort
I expended during say 30 minutes in the
pool it was just it was a huge shift for
me and I think that applies to
producing quality in many many different
areas at least in my experience somewhat
counter-intuitively so what when did the
sort of the the bones of what would
later become Total Immersion start to
coalesce or start to appear
well the powerful impact of working on
technique and not neglecting
conditioning whatsoever I my swimmers
were very well conditioned everywhere I
coached but the conditioning was always
subordinate to the form in other words I
would stop a set if I wasn't satisfied
with the form they might be swimming
fast they might be swimming their hearts
out but if I was not satisfied with the
form I would stop the set redirect and
restart the set and say you must
maintain your form the beginning of my
conviction that that was that was an
absolute that swimming success is based
on superior form came that first season
that at Kings point I had I had swum in
that conference for four years I swam
for st. John's University and we were we
swam against Kings Point for four years
we swam in the conference championship
each year and I took I took my team
after doing all this technique work and
radically reshaping their strokes I have
to say to to the conference championship
and at the at the end of the season and
we just set the place on fire I just
could not you know even having coached
them the whole season I just was my mind
was kind of boggled by by the times they
swam simply because nothing in my
experience prepared me to see swimmers
improve that much and swim that fast
compared to the previous year I'll give
you one example sort of the premier
event in college swimming is the 4 by
100 freestyle relay it's always the
final event in the Innoko
championship mate and as for his four
swimmers each lemming 100 yards or 100
metres and in the four years that I was
in the conference the the conference
record for that event improved from 325
to 323 and as it happened I was
fortunate that the when I was a senior
the record of 320 3.8 was set by my bike
by Kings Point relay so I inherited the
the championship and and record-holding
relay well they they came back my first
year coaching and went 316 Wow and won
in one night they improved seven seconds
of what had you know what it improves
two seconds in four years and
everybody's jaws were hanging around the
pool and I realized oh my goodness what
have I brought I had never done anything
that you you know would suggest
distinction of any sort in my life prior
to that night what what year do you
recall the year on that yeah that was
March of 1973 okay so that and I was I
was still 21 years old for goodness
sakes and now you ended up producing and
I want to sort of qualify my year
earlier statement also 24 National Club
and college champions right if I'm
getting my facts straight so I don't
want to imply that conditioning isn't a
piece of successfully coaching a
competitive team certainly but that it's
necessary but not sufficient
right I mean to produce the improvement
that you did in the relay you can't just
have them train harder or expend more
calories in the pool it was a it was a
technical improvement and I think that
right right there's no way any change in
conditioning anything I could have done
in workouts could have produced that
improvement no way at all no tell me
tell me about Bill boomer I
[Music]
where did bill into the picture and what
what effect did he have
so I actually met bill bloomer in 1988
and I I was just ready to step away from
coaching I had gotten burned out I'd
still love coaching I loved teaching but
I was I had gotten a little burned out
on dealing with parents before we before
we just gloss over that so can you give
us an example like what type of stuff
burned you out with parents yeah well
there was one time where I had these two
really sensational twelve year old boys
and when I had really good swimmers
I would I would make things a little
more challenging for them I didn't want
it to come to easily because at age 12
when you're a dominant swimmer you're
not used to being challenged so we got
to our season our our net our state age
group championships and I said to the to
the 12 year old boys out of the eight
events you're going to swim you can
choose six but I'm going to choose two
and they both knew what it would be it
was going to be that they were both
going to swim breaststroke events
because that was their weakest event and
I I wanted them to have at least you
know one or two races where they really
had to race and not just race each other
and one once one of the boys the parents
came to the end complained bitterly
about my forcing their son to do that he
had no problem with it he didn't he
didn't have an objection or had not
raised an objection but because it was
going to hurt his chances of winning the
high point award and you know and I'm
thinking about his long-term development
not whether he wins the trophy at age 12
or and in the end the other boy who's
who his parents were fully supported he
and his parents were fully supported and
he swam the breaststroke events and I
decided it wasn't worth fighting that
battle that if it was that important I'd
let him not swim breaststroke but the
other boy swam the breaststroke and
ended up winning the high point award
so you're burning out because of
overzealous or maybe over involved over
vocal parents yeah they just lost their
sense of perspective and in in it and
bill boomer came came into the came into
the picture around that time
yeah so I'm 37 years old and I have no
money in the bank I you know I also had
a fourteen-year-old daughter who was I
was thinking I've got college costs
coming up and you know coaching just
didn't pay well I was one of the most
successful most respected coaches in in
the United States is in the age group
ranks and I I had never earned more than
fifteen thousand dollars in a season and
had no money in the bank so I just
decided I was gonna cast about see what
what else I'm my my native abilities
might allow me to do that might pay
better and so but I still wanted to
coach I still wanted to be keep my hand
in it I went I was invited to the
American swimming Coaches Association
world clinic it's it's the top coaching
clinic in the world and I was invited to
talk on a topic related to age group
swimming and then immediately after I
finished my talk I was sitting in the
back of the room sort of decompressing
with some coaching friends and I had
intended to go see Randy Reis the head
coach of the University of Florida at
the time and a guy who had coached many
Olympians and world record holders and
by the way the brother Eddie rhesus
coach at University of Texas at Austin
and and probably the most successful
coach we have in the United States so I
was going to go see Randy Reece and
learn how to coach world record holders
and and Bill boomer and it completely
under lid on little-known coach with a
really unconventional approach to things
he was a coach at the University of
Rochester in Rochester New York and
he got up and started speaking and he
just right right from his opening
sentences it blew my mind he was talking
about things I had never heard and the
most the thing that he said that has
stuck with me ever since that I'll stay
I'll quote two quotes of his but the
first was he says the shape of the
engine is more important than the sorry
the shape of the vessel is more
important than the size of the engine in
swimming and every every coaching talk I
had been to of the probe of the previous
16 years of going to coaching clinics
everyone had been about engine building
not a single talk about vessel shaping
what do we really mean by this that well
Boomer says that a human body moving
through the water should be treated like
any vessel and should be designed to
move through the water with as little
drag and as little turbulence as as
possible and engine building referred to
both building the aerobic engine through
through cardiovascular conditioning and
emphasizing how powerful the potent kick
is I by doing what I call arms
department legs Department training
where you you tie your legs together you
you you know you put a buoy between them
and a bit and a band around them take
them out of the picture and then to put
a pair of big paddles on your hands and
and muscle your way up and down the pool
with your arm muscles or you immobilize
your arms and and possibly put on fins
for more more power and muscle your way
up and down the pool and separating the
arms from the legs and in training dis
integrating the body in other words so
so the two types of engine building is
is really all that I had ever heard
emphasized and and that was the first
thing and I'll come back with another
anecdote later to tell you why this
resonated with me but the other thing
that he said was that conditioning is
something that
happens to you while you build refine
and imprint skills and just the fact
that you know you would first look at
the skill component first look at the
skill impact of any training set or
tasks you give and that the metabolic
component the conditioning component
would be a factor of the difficulty of
the skill task as opposed to just say to
say to the swimmer I want your heart
rate above 170 for you know for the next
20 minutes ready go and you know before
before we keep moving head with the
chronology I'd love to talk about your
experience which I think was maybe it
was just before this you could clarify
when exactly it happened but the the
break that you took from coaching can
you tell us a bit about that experience
when you start it when you were testing
other avenues for making a living yeah
it ended up being writing I had started
doing just a little bit of writing beep
while I was still coaching I wrote one
article for Swimming World magazine and
wrote a few other things for newsletters
I always wrote a piece for our club
newsletter you know from the coaches
perspective and I found I enjoyed
communicating by writing and I thought I
would try so my wife Alice and I started
a marketing communications very tiny
little mom-and-pop agency called Main
Street communications we lived on Main
Street in Goshen New York and and we
wrote speeches and PR stuff and things
like that for small businesses in the
area at the same time I started writing
articles for smooth for small local
magazines and then I happen to go to my
2003 high school reunion and one of my
classmates was the editor
of a magazine on corporate hedging on
how multinational companies hedge their
currency risk which was much greater in
those days before the before the
unification of the eurozone there were
all those currencies in Europe and so
they were they were at great risk of
currency moves and interest rate risk
and political risk and commodity risk
all these forms of risks that you
undertake and so I you know we said what
are you doing I said well I'm doing a
little bit of magazine writing he said
said why don't you send me a clip and he
ended up giving me assignment and I I
you know it turned out I was pretty good
at interviewing and distilling the
information and and and writing about it
even though I knew nothing about puts
and calls and and all these hedging
strategies and so I ended up I earned my
living primarily through writing about
international corporate finance which is
kind of a crazy thing during during the
time that I wasn't coaching why did you
come back to coaching well I you know I
wasn't away from coaching very long I
actually was an assistant coach at West
Point with a responsibility to be the my
portfolio was coaching technique for
everybody on the team my good friend ray
bossy had just taken over as head coach
and he asked me to help him make the
transition during his first year so I
did that was 1988-89 when I had started
the writing and stuff and I enjoyed just
working on tech always that enjoyed
teaching technique and in 1988 in August
of 1988 I resumed swimming I had not
swum in 17 years since college and I saw
that masters Nationals were going to be
in Buffalo not far from my house so I
thought well I'll start swimming again
and I'll go to that massive Nationals
and see how I like it
so the the takeaways I got
that everybody seemed to be having great
fun and I was super impressed by the
people in the 55 and over age groups how
fit they were and how fast they were and
I thought I want to be like them when I
get to be that age so so I was I was
introduced to master swimming and I
thought well if I if I coached these
folks I probably won't have any parent
problems and so at the next summer I
decided I was going to hold a summer
camp that summer camps for kids were a
common thing you know there was like
other sports
there were week long and longer summer
camps for different sports so summer
camps or swimmers were something I knew
well and I thought I'd offer one for
adults and so I did 19 June of 1989 at
Colgate University in Hamilton New York
I had the first ever total immersion
camp where did I get the name total
immersion because I didn't want to call
it Terry Laughlin swim camp to me that
was like calling it some guys swim camp
I thought I needed a better name than
just my name so I was I was reading a
magazine one day and I came across an ad
for Berlitz language schools and they
were offering what they called total
immersion language courses and I said
that certainly works as well for
swimming as it does for for language so
I chose that name and then waited about
five years for a letter from their
lawyers telling me to cease and desist
before I went to a lawyer and found it
oh I could I could trademark total
immersion swimming which I did finally
so I had total immersion swim camp in
the summer of 89 and I had six swimmers
the first week in nine the second I had
I had an Olympic swimmer a 1948 Olympian
from from Holland who was now a resident
of Canada of unto Ottawa and and came to
the camp and so I I talked I taught
those people what I had been teaching
for 20 years or not 20 years but 18
years 17 years I what I had been
teaching to age group swimmers because
these people were all
very conversant with swimming a lot of
them it's one when they were kids you
know not to mention having an Olympian
and they were all very comfortable in
the water and you know everything
everything that I did work well with
them and you know couple of them said I
improved more in five days and I have in
the last 10 years so that was something
that I I found I enjoyed I found worked
well with the people and I continued
doing that for the next for the next
several years but I I had master
swimmers the first year and the third
year I had my first triathlete come come
to one of these four stroke camps and
first of all they were mainly interested
in in freestyle not in the other three
strokes and secondly when we finished a
pool session we had two full sessions a
day one morning one afternoon and I I
wanted them to rest up for the afternoon
they would go out for a bike ride to her
run and come back all sweaty so I wasn't
thrilled but it the the proportion of
triathletes grew so rapidly that by
about the fourth or fifth year it was
70% triathletes and we were doing just
freestyle now we're if we're gonna let's
the if you don't mind
flash forward as you're so you're
forming Total Immersion you're
developing and testing different methods
if we look back at our experience that
we shared in Hawaii with Sara who was
very much
novice swimmer uncomfortable putting her
face underwater right mother of I think
too at the time and for the tim ferriss
experiment a TV show at the time we
wanted to show demonstrate that it
wasn't just an anomaly that I had
learned to swim in this way and that in
fact it could be replicated so we
brought Sara to Hawaii and I'm gonna
back into the technique but started with
kind of coughing and having a lot of
trouble really just submerging her face
too a few days later and keeping in mind
that for those people who
non-fiction TV or reality TV if it's
actually reality TV which this was
meaning it's not highly scripted we're
actually capturing someone as they
progress from 0 to hopefully open water
swimmer yeah there's a longer you're
really on the line and also you have
audio issues you have camera reframing
so you might think that with say Sarah
we had four or five days of training but
in reality we had a much shortened
period of time is probably half of that
time that we had to work very
complicated and challenging
instructional environment with all the
all the technical people around and all
the cameras and the reshoots and all of
that yeah it really it but it worked and
she ended up swimming in very deep water
open water sink swimming with both of us
and breathing in freestyle stroke it was
just tremendous but where do you take
someone like Sarah and begin where do
you start because I think this is where
a lot of people who try to learn to swim
and you know they swallow their pride
and go to the pool or find a coach where
things go sideways and certainly that
was true for me
where do you start do you start by
getting into the deep end and trying to
learn how to breathe while you swim
freestyle very very small bits very what
I call mini skills and micro skills
we we always teach in a step-by-step
fashion where each step leads naturally
to the next and as a scaffold for for
the next step so so I meet Sarah at the
at the pool on Monday morning we began
the shoot on Monday morning and we I
said okay well let's see what you can do
and the cameras are rolling and Sarah
swims about six or eight strokes
furiously just just flailing away with
their head out of the water head
just whipping back and forth and then
she needs a breath and what did she do
she stopped she can't breathe and swim
so she had to stop and she did that a
few times and I I knew you know I had a
pretty good idea what what I was gonna
say and you probably recognized that
from your own experience Tim oh sure you
know the way she was swimming and
survived the drowning monkey technique
yeah right well you know here I I cited
the statistic earlier of only two
percent of American adults can swim four
meters non-stop only 30 percent can swim
25 yards just one you know one length of
your local local pool only thirty
percent can can swim one lap non-stop so
that was you Tim as I recall your story
was you're gonna in a 20 yard pool and
swimming about two-thirds of the way the
way down and not being able to get past
that two thirds 2/3 points so it what is
it it's an inability to breathe if you
can't get air you can't carry on but you
can't just start in with breathing
because there's there's a series of
skills that you have to learn first so
what if we have Sara do first doing a
glide a very very simple glide with arms
extended at shoulder width we call that
Superman
it's Superman I just as instructing
instructing Sara to just glide to just
hang her head between her shoulders
which is and then it's an it's a non
instinctive thing but exceptionally
important in fact it's counterintuitive
what was Sarah's instinct was to hold
her head up to avoid choking and I hear
I was telling her sir I want you to hang
your head in the water I want you to let
it go and she discovered when she she
let her head hang in the water that she
could glide and her body didn't sink and
she could just glide effortlessly maybe
five or six yards and that's
of that that's a life-changing
experience for someone who's always felt
that they they were sinker right well
you're showing the the how the shape of
the vessel right the hydrodynamics
exchange is the whole game or we in fact
were shaping the vessel to two so that
she could glide five or six yards
without any effort so that she could
just look down and see the pull bottom
passing under her without her doing
anything and at the same time feel this
incredible sense of support almost
weightlessness from the water and I just
want to highlight something here or a
few things the first is that this is
happening in let's call it four feet of
water right right so Sarah can stand up
at any time
if she wants to yeah it's removing that
fear factor second she's not kicking
she's not pulling with her hands she's
simply gliding right so you're gliding
and shaping the vessel yeah so you're
isolating that prerequisite skill or
component that leads to the rest and one
thing that really struck me and this is
true in my experience with all really
really profound instruction whether it's
music or say recently for me tennis with
a coach named Lorenzo Beltrami who just
blew my mind with teaching me how to
serve properly and I just want to draw a
parallel if you don't mind the
digression because or Josh Waitzkin has
been on this podcast and how he teaches
chess which is very much what you would
not expect and what you find is that
almost by definition really profound
instruction is very different from what
you would expect because what you expect
gets very mediocre results and and for
instance you know Josh starts with and I
think we'll come back to this but first
principles right he wants he wants
someone to understand the principles of
chess in this case and for those people
who don't know the name he was the basis
for the book in the movie searching for
Bobby Fischer and he'll take all
the pieces off the chessboard and start
with a I think it's just King versus
King and pawn to teach very very
flexible principles that then apply to
the rest of the game so he'll start with
the endgame in order to demonstrate
those principles but perhaps a more
direct parallel would be Lorenzo when he
was teaching me I'd never been able to
serve in tennis oh really I never had
learned how to play tennis period but
what he started me with is he said all
right you're gonna hold the tennis ball
in your left hand and you want your
hands sideways all right it's that so
that you're not whipping the ball
backwards and I want you to just
practice throwing the ball up and having
it land a few inches in front of your
feet that's all I want you to do so I'm
just throwing the tennis ball up having
it land in front of my feet so that I'm
not throwing it behind me or too far
ahead of me because okay great
actually if I take it back that was step
two step one was practice lightly and
loosely throwing a tennis ball over the
net just like a just like a soft
baseball thrown second was with my left
hand throwing the ball up and having it
land in front of me just a few inches in
front of my foot then the next step was
throwing the first ball up and then
trying to hit it within the tennis ball
that I'm throwing with my rear hand and
then literally he just said okay here's
a tennis racket try to hit the tennis
ball and boom right into the zone the
other side of the net and it just was
one of those moments and that just made
my head kind of explode which was also
the case with Total Immersion and with
this logical progression that's right
what I want to underscore is that you're
building on each of these skills and it
just gets me so excited when people ask
me you know why are you trying to learn
the gamelan from Indonesia why are you
trying to learn this or that it's these
aha moments where you do something for
say Sarah and she goes holy [ __ ]
for lack of a better more elegant way to
put it I could actually do this yeah and
see you have Sara gliding what are some
of the other important initial skills or
exercises that you layer on top of that
well one of the things that that you
have written in your you know when you
write about meta learning one of the
principles that you have cited for that
is avoid error points right and as soon
as I as I read that I recognized oh yeah
we did that
you know Tim kids got it and what are
the two error points and you know from
your experience what are the two error
points for swimmers oh boy you know and
I'm caught on the spot I would say well
number one is just fear of not being
able to touch the bottom at least for me
yeah all this name and for those people
who are wondering what I mean so if
we're looking at failure points I can I
can tell you the two you decided when
you wrote yeah I wrote about it yeah and
kicking and breathing kicking and
breathing right thinking and breathing
because every every time somebody handed
you a kick board as you said your feet
just slice through the water like razor
blades when you wet know where yeah
everybody's experience nobody can propel
on a cake board except really people who
are already really good swimmers yeah so
so that's a totally useless tool to
learn to swim but everybody what do they
do what does everybody do they hand you
a kick board to try to strengthen your
legs so your legs won't sink that's not
the problem you're having weak legs is
not the problem
so the problem the first problem we
solved with Sarah was fear of fear
sinking mm-hmm
and we took out the breathing component
we said we're gonna add that later when
when you are ready when you have when
you have a platform of skills so that
you can control something about how you
breathe them we'll introduce that and
you know we're gonna not even make
kicking part of it at all but teach you
as you have written Tim to have the legs
draft behind the upper body so so we had
her do exactly that with it with the the
Superman glide which is just let out a
pearl sized string of bubbles so that
you're not holding your breath
and don't take press your legs lightly
together and just feel your body body
gliding that was that was step one the
second step was to teach her to shape
her body for the most hydrodynamic
position in the crawl stroke in the most
hydrodynamic position the one where you
experienced the least drag is the fully
extended position so when you've reached
forward with one arm and and pressed
back with the other arm and you're fully
extended and rotated of just a little
bit off your stomach so we call that
skate position because it brings to mind
or I would like to bring to mind the
blade of a speed skate and to shape your
body to be as long and sleek and
balanced as as it can be and so what we
did there was the Superman Glide does
not occur in freestyle so we just used
that to get her comfortable in the water
to give her a sense that she had control
of her body position very important to
feel that you're in control and then and
then the very next step was to put her
in the most hydrodynamic position so we
started with the most important moment
in the stroke and and let her become
very very familiar with all the fine
details of that moment where should your
hand be your extended hand be it should
be in a particular place it should be
below your body and it should be on on a
track with the whole right side of your
body if it's your right arm and your
left shoulder should be barely above the
surface you should be looking straight
down you should be kicking very very
minimally and so we taught her that
position I would say we spent a good
part of an entire pool session just a
letting Sally Sarah become familiar with
and in control of that that position
no definitely and I a couple of things
that come to mind that I also want to
bring
that were particularly helpful for me
number one was having a and I'm very
quantified and since that I like to have
a number I can use for tracking
improvement but when you're just
learning how to swim looking at say laps
be it is is going to encourage bad
behavior right it's gonna again courage
at least in me the thrashing and over
exertion that we want to avoid
but the looking at the sort of stroke
count per length ended up being really
helpful for me so for instance you know
I went from in about four workouts this
is again by myself just self coaching
with the book more than twenty five
strokes per 20-yard length to an average
of around eleven strokes so I had I had
doubled my sort of efficiency right and
I'll just run through a couple of quick
notes that I have here so the first is
more of a meta comment which is people
think of swimming and I thought of
swimming as something you do on top of
the water and I'll just list a few of
these and then we can we can dig in to
dig into them but whereas in fact your
body's denser that or very often denser
than water are you're going to be mostly
submerged so we think of freestyle as as
having say ninety percent you can give
you probably more accurately ninety
percent of your body
under water then when you are swimming
say freestyle your body is going to be
mostly under water and just accepting
that removes a huge fear factor because
if you're accustomed to thinking I have
to swim in order to breathe enough to
keep my body on top of the water you're
on a suicide mission it's just not gonna
work the physics don't provide for it
yeah gravity is always gonna win so when
you but when you're taught from the very
outset or the expectation is set all
right your body is gonna be ninety five
ninety ninety five percent under water
and your goal and let's start by kicking
off a wall and four feet of water is to
glide from say-so
of fuselage right to fuselage left right
so if we think of freestyle not as
swimming on your stomach but from
alternating from one extended position
to the other just like you would go from
say right speed skate to left speed
skate like you're imagining earlier in
that extended position things change
really really quickly and thinking of
these are just a couple of the
counterintuitive things I want to
mention for people that really helped me
another was focusing on driving your arm
through the water as opposed to pulling
in order to encourage that position the
looking straight down which you
mentioned also I think very
counterintuitive for folks and having
your arm when you are in that fully
extended position a good deal underwater
I'm not on top of the water and what
that does is helps to apply water
pressure on the arm and raise the legs
right so my issue or what I call that
the trim tab effect so the weight should
that the trim tabs on an airplane our
airplane work to raise or lower the nose
if you have something in front the
hydrodynamics and aerodynamics or work
exactly the same and if you have
something in front of the vessel that is
angled down it's going to lift the rear
and and that's so the arm is acting as a
trim tab for your body and effortlessly
lifting your legs to the surface meaning
to two really important things one is
you save on the energy of kicking and
the second is you you save a huge amount
of turbulence and drag so just you know
using the arm in that way who would ever
think that you know that's more
important than pushing water back what
are some of the the drills or exercises
that you've found most helpful for
translating or translating to most of
the components you want to emphasize
into one exercise so one that I found
just really really tremendously helpful
was hand swapping so if you have to talk
to perhaps you know
front quadrant swimming a little bit but
the idea that you know what what when in
doubt if I feel like I'm getting a
little panicky or getting tired or
whatever it might be I think of of hand
swapping could you could you describe
what that means for people sure
so our innate primal instinct when we
start swimming is to windmill the arms
heedlessly just just turn away with the
arms meaning generally the arms are
going to be a hundred and eighty degrees
apart or close to it and not only are
you not creating much propulsion by
windmilling your arms you're also
creating a whole lot of drag that's a
sort of a fatal prescription for getting
anywhere and so we always have
prioritized what we call vessel shaping
or shaping shaping your human swimming
body to minimize drag during all moments
in the stroke and so the first thing you
can do to minimize drag is use your arm
to lengthen your body the longer the
body is the less the less drag there is
and then you need to think a little bit
about stroke timing in in terms of that
because you want to keep the body long
for a bit more of the recovery recovery
is when you're bringing your arm forward
so essentially we're teaching people to
leave the extended arm forward until the
other arm is just about to re-enter the
water after completing its recovery and
and not simply to leave it there but to
hold your place - to actively use your
hand to hold your place because you're
going to spear the other hand once you
once you enter the water you're going to
spirit past your grip and use use power
from the high side of the body to move
past your grip so instead of propelling
with just your arm and shoulder muscles
you're propelling with your whole body
so this is I mean what we're really
deconstructing in a way is
progressive mastery of a given skill
yeah it would seem to me and you I know
our big fan of a book titled mastery by
George Leonard right can you tell us
about how you how you found that book
and your experience in in reading and
I'd like to dig into it just a little
bit because I think it's widely
applicable yeah sometime in the 1990s
somebody someone brought to my attention
a magazine article he had he had written
for I believe Esquire in in the late 80s
and it was more reprints were requests
of that article than any other article
they were they had ever printed and it
was about mastery and the story George
was telling was that of taking up Aikido
at age 47 a very advanced age and then
becoming the latest starter ever to
reach the to reach the master teacher
level in Aikido and and how did he
manage manage to accomplish that and it
was it's just a set of a set of
prescriptions or principles for for
attaining mastery and and you know the
the essential idea of of this is that
life is not designed to make things easy
for us but to present us with challenges
that help us grow and that we should
embrace these challenges and and you
know something you've done for many
years Tim that we should embrace these
challenges and if we apply certain
behaviors we're gonna we're gonna
experience a lot more success and and so
the behaviors he cited were first of all
always be focused on improving the skill
itself and anytime you are doing it
you're focused on improving the skill
the amount of time you spend what your
heart rate is or any of that is
secondary to doing things that improve
the skill
a second is to focus on weak points
don't focus on your strengths a third
and I really love this one this one is
my favorite is to love the plateau in
anything we learn we initially as we're
working our way through the most basic
and easiest skills we learn pretty
rapidly and then things start to slow
down and then things may slow down to
the point where you only experience a
breakthrough every 6 to 12 months or so
and George George Leonard wrote that
when you practice with with guided by
the principles of mastery there is
always positive change taking place at
the cellular level below your threshold
of awareness and that periodically this
change consolidates into a thrilling
leap forward which was very much my own
experience I proved it to myself with my
own experience where by the time I had
been by the time I had been swimming
fifty years in other words I'm in my
mid-60s and I've really been swimming 50
years maybe even a you know 51 52 years
I was still learning things that
thrilled me I was still getting insights
about my own stroke that were literally
thrilling and they were coming at really
really long intervals and so having read
George Leonard you know long before I
was in my 60s I was really prepared for
for that eventuality
can you teach people to love the plateau
or their ingredients that help people to
persists through a plateau yeah what
what and if so what are they because I
think that this is such a common
quitting point for a lot of people where
they are
myself included I'm not immune to this
we'll get the sort of the the sugar high
of the initial aha moments and making
rapid progress and rapid experiencing
rapid
and then uh-oh now it's very very
incremental now it's barely perceptible
and I feel like I'm not making progress
or even backsliding how do you how would
you help someone to persist through that
plateau and and I suppose learn to love
it if possible yeah well I think there's
a couple of things no I think one of the
things you want to do is give give them
enough of the right sort of information
about the foundations of excellence in
what they have taken up that they become
curious to learn more so so first you
need to stimulate their curiosity and
eventually you get to what I hope for
you know for everyone I teach I hope
becomes passionate curiosity where you
know so you move from curiosity to being
really intrigued to wanting to really
solve this to becoming passionate about
it and it's it's that hierarchy you've
got to love what you're doing and there
you know there's there's a good deal
there's a good deal of evidence about
what causes people to love what they're
doing and one of the most important is
is simply the goal of enjoying enjoy it
today if I'm going to work out for an
hour my goal is to enjoy my my hour of
work out at the beginning of the year
health clubs all over see see a flock of
people signing up and they sign up far
more people than they can actually serve
because they know that about two-thirds
of them are gonna not use their
membership they're gonna you know
they're gonna start out with all the
fire and and then lose it and stop going
to the gym and there there's been
there's been a pretty authoritative
study that showed the main difference
between the people who continued using
their membership and those who do not
was that you those who we use we're not
stop using their membership had in mind
some some benefit they might receive in
six months time while the people who use
their membership and stayed with it
just enjoyed going to the gym everyday
they did things that brought them
pleasure in the moments so I think
pleasure in the moment this is really
important and what the other thing is
you've got to be really engaged with it
and it's if I see people on the aerobic
equipment at my gym what do I see well
some of them are reading books and
disassociating from what they're doing
and others are really paying attention
to what they're doing they may be using
an elliptical machine or or a running
treadmill or something for the umpteenth
time but they're still finding details
about how they use that machine that are
worth their attention so what what might
some of those details be and I'll I'll
add a few that I found helpful it's for
persisting in the face of a potential
say technical plateau right or even a
strength plateau for instance in the
case of strength training so a few
things that that help me to continue
number one is in the case of swimming
recognizing the sort of beneficial
mental shift and emotional psychological
shift that takes place in me even if I
am not swimming more laps or improving
times my state coming out of the pool is
almost always better than it was going
into the pool I just feel better and so
that has benefits even if I'm not say
developing towards being a top
competitive swimmer the second and this
is true for me and almost everything but
I have measurables
so and it doesn't mean that I'm tracking
my measurables from workout to workout
but it gives me I felt I find the act of
counting very meditative so the fact
that I have for instance and weight
training usually there's a cadence let's
say it's two seconds up four seconds
down or yesterday I did a workout where
I was doing five seconds up five seconds
down so there's a there's a there's a
tempo counting and then there's a
repetition counting and then I'm logging
the sets and I find for whatever reason
that increases my adherence to something
if I have
a quantification in the case of swimming
I have the one two three one two three
of breathing on alternate sides and then
I also have the strokes per length that
I can focus on or the hand swapping
drill and the last that comes to mind is
specifically as it relates to swimming
because there is I think still a tiny
part of me in the back of my head that
is afraid of drowning I mean there's
there's a tiny part that still has the
fear cumulated over 30 years and I'm
comfortable in the water but what I
think helps me to continue to want to go
back to the pool is always doing less
than what I feel capable of doing which
is very much the opposite of what I've
done almost every in almost every other
place not everywhere but in the case of
swimming there are a few other places
where you have fine motor skill tennis
also true doing less than I feel is
possible so in other words stopping
before my technique really deteriorates
Oh ice with very short periods of time I
would say typically less than 45 minutes
very good okay got it yeah I mean I
would say very often I'll go in and I'll
do 20 to 30 minutes it's not it's not a
it's not a long workout and I try not to
view it as a workout it's really a a
practice of moving meditation for me and
if I want to smash my body in some type
of other training that's fine but in the
pool I view it much more as a practice
in elegance and efficiency rather to the
greatest extent possible you're moving
you're moving through a fluid what could
be better than flow in your own movement
right now I you know there's there's a I
see I took a note here and I don't know
the story so I'll bring it up this is it
looks like from 2000 and
the story of Phil Cruz I can you tell me
who Phil Cruz's sure what happened in
2000 yeah I think well I think maybe
1999 I did a workshop in Chapel Hill we
had maybe 20 20 attendees and we had one
in particular who was the most
challenged student that that I had yet
seen he did what Sarah did during our
first videotape they thrashed about five
strokes and stood up to breathe and and
that was it
and by the end of the two-day workshop
on Sunday afternoon it was a triumph for
him to not navigate one length of the
pool continuously was with a hybrid
between it between drilling and swimming
it wasn't even a whole stroke so fast
forward eighteen months and I'm teaching
what we call a Kaizen camp in Florida
and it's a four stroke camp if you want
to learn all four strokes and our
streams being freestyle backstroke
breaststroke butterfly and butterfly
correct and they didn't have to do four
strokes but they could do any number of
the four that they wanted and we
videotaped everybody in the first
session to get them before before
picture and any of the strokes that you
wanted and while we were videotaping
freestyle one of these one of these camp
participants when the most unbelievably
beautiful freestyle at the at the level
of our best coaches just that that sort
of Grace and fluency and ease and so you
know aft afterward I said where did you
learn that and he said from you it
became became clear that he was the
person who had attended
you know we've been at that that such a
such a challenge for more 18 months
earlier in Chapel Hill and not only that
but he was a soybean farmer he had
previously worked in a management
position and then became a gentleman
farmer after after retiring from that
but he he farmed soybeans in coastal
North Carolina and he was 25 miles from
the nearest pool so in that intervening
18 months I mean everybody we teach
improves okay so I'm not that's not the
standard it's just my mind was blown by
the degree to which he improved and then
I found out he did it entirely on his
own he had no other resources or help or
anything and you know I was just driving
himself to the YMCA 25 miles away and
did it at night and in a year and a half
on his own and I became what that
stimulated in me was a curiosity one
show someone shows absolutely no knack
for something how did they get that good
that was that that was something that
really intrigued me so what was the what
were the what were the components and
what were what went into his practice
what did he do do you think that led to
that degree of improvement yeah you know
I'd say first of all not everybody is as
good as he is or as you were itself
coaching so he started out he did
started out with some coaching but it
was just two days of coaching and then
18 months on his own so I I suppose he
probably had probably pretty pretty well
acquainted with his body for whatever
reason that's that's one thing but the
second thing is he I think he probably
just faithfully followed through on
practicing the drills very patiently
very attentively until he really
understood them and constantly refined
his his form in the drills and then and
then taking whatever he learned from the
drills and putting it into into all
stroke practice he probably gave not a
moment's thought to speed or how far he
was swimming I'll bet he did what you
did Tim which was to only practice for
as long as he felt the practice was
fruitful the other were I mean a handful
of things that I think in any practice
for me at least helped with self
coaching the the first would be whenever
possible having a as as they would say
in the syrup world a key performance
indicator so what is the number that you
are trying to improve week on week and
there's there's actually a very famous
for lack of or to keep it simple I'll
say a startup incubator called Y
Combinator nicknamed YC based in Silicon
Valley that can be thought of as the
Harvard meets SEAL Team six of startup
training and they bring in a very very
small percentage of people who apply and
work them into the ground 24/7 or these
people don't really need help to do that
they'll do it on their own and at the
end they have a business that they pitch
to investors and so on and during that
period they almost all choose a KPI a
key performance indicator and the goal
is to say improve it 10% week on week so
for me and swimming I decided early on
with the help of Total Immersion in book
form and then later I got the DVDs was
the stroke count the number of strokes
per lap and that was my that was my true
north like anything that I did that hurt
that I ended up either fixing or
discarding and anything I did that
improved that I would continue
practicing and then on top of that I
would test all of these various drills
and realized for myself that the hand
swapping drill not saying it's true for
everyone but in my case focusing on that
front quadrant swimming and the hand
swapping was what most
quickly returned me to a very optimal
for me in my skill level stroke per lap
if that made sense and then last and
this is actually much easier now at the
time GoPro either didn't exist or was
very very early and kind of version 1v1
type technology but having some means of
video observation or correction I just
think is so incredibly helpful and I've
used that in swimming to a lesser extent
but only when we had the gear in Hawaii
to do so and of course in my head
I've been practicing total immersion for
a while at that point I was like okay
you know I I feel like Mike my
techniques are pretty good and then you
see it on camera and you just wanna
cringe and that was also true when I was
in Argentina in 2004-2005 and ended up
competing in tango and I mean I ended up
going to the World Championships and
making it to the semi finals but about I
would say three months prior to that I
remember I was two or three months into
practicing tango felt like I had really
made a lot of progress I had been taking
video of different instructors different
dancers I'd been cataloging technique I
had been writing down my specific goals
for each as I viewed it practice session
/ workout and then I would have one or
two things each day that I would work on
in the uncontrolled environment of a
milonga which is a dance hall so I
thought I was not hot [ __ ] but I thought
that I was really on my road to being a
fantastic dancer and then I remember I
went and I bought a video camera this is
on Avenida Flo Rida in window scientist
and where they have a lot of electronic
stores so I bought this camera took it
to practice had somebody record me
dancing with this woman and it was
horrible
it's just it look what what I was doing
in my head and what I was doing on the
camera were so different that they would
have been on wreck I mean you would
ever have paired my video to what I
would have described myself doing and
that is what allowed me though that sort
of harsh reality is what allowed me to
really really really improve after that
point are there any other types of
practice or types of self-talk any types
of planning or journaling or anything
that you have seen helpful or that
you've observed in people who self coach
well because I think this is such an
important skill if you're trying to get
if you want to be an autodidact and most
of the time even if you have access to
good coaches you will be without a coach
you know water what are some of the
things that you've seen contribute to
good self coaching yes video very very
important tool very helpful tool for
anything more movement orient there has
never been a time that I have been
videotaped that I was satisfied with
what I saw to this day but you know if I
can cite my own experience because I did
my hell in Total Immersion coach all
along I I got into you know once I I
have to step back a little bit and talk
about how my mind was open to how how
much it how much potential improvement
was available to me that I had not
realized at all going back to Bill
boomer after I heard him talk at that
clinic I I drove up to Rochester to
watch him coach and see him put into
practice the things he talked about and
pick his brain and one of the things
that he talked about was that the
Keystone skill of swimming was balanced
now I had never even heard of balanced
as a skill of swimming and he was saying
it was the Keystone to efficiency so he
talked about balance during the during
the clinic thing and then when I went up
I said bill would you teach me something
about balance so he he taught me a drill
that he called pressing the buoy or
pressing the T excuse me
he called it pressing the T where you
would have your arms at your sides and
be flutter kicking with your head in
line with your spine and lean on your
chest as you do so so I did that and I
had spent 25 years thinking I had the
misfortune to be born with heavy legs
it's a bad thing as a swimmer to be born
with heavy legs
and I spent a quarter century thinking I
was doomed and in 10 seconds doing this
drill if that that whole concept was
exploded because my legs were light and
I never realized that I could you know I
had the power to do something to change
that can you explain the drill one more
time please yeah yeah we we teach it
today we call it torpedo but we do it
without the flutter kick but but
essentially you put your arms at your
sides and you glide with your head in
line with your spine
kicking gently and and lean a little bit
on your chest and what you feel is your
hips and legs become lighter that
they're lifted by the a lever effect you
you know a lever effect of leaning
what's the most buoyant part of your
body is your chest you've got you've got
about you you've got a your lungs in
there that holds six liters are there
that's the most buoyant part of the body
and so when you lean it's like pressing
pressing a volleyball into the water
press press down on a volleyball it's
going to push back so if you keep
pressing it's gonna push back somewhere
else and it lifts up your hips and legs
God and that's he called that pressing
the T because the T was the intersection
of your spine and if you stretch your
arms out to the side that's was so I
there's I was I was depending on maybe
talking about this earlier but I want to
be respectful of your time and I also
want to make sure that we chat about
your cancer diagnosis and I have I have
some questions about that but could you
tell people the the origin of the cancer
diagnosis
and perhaps just explain the the
circumstances yeah just about two years
ago I went with two friends to Sardinia
and we swam from course ago which is in
France to Sardinia and I had an
unbelievably great swim I had you know I
had been not training exceptionally hard
for it it's a it's a ten mile swim the
water temperature was sixty four sixty
five and it took us four and a half
hours and that was stopping every thirty
minutes so there were seven stops for
four to have a feed which happened to be
blueberry soup one of my coast warmers
was from Sweden and brought blueberries
blue bar SOPA and just an incredible
swim one of the best ones in my life I
and so I came home and within a week of
coming home I got I had my annual
physical and my my doctor found some
irregularities when he examined my
prostate and he said you need to get a
biopsy from the urologist I went very
quickly to get the biopsy and the biopsy
turned out to be positive for cancer and
it was what's called a Gleason score of
four plus three or seven and what's
significant about that is the number
four in indicates how aggressive the
cancer is and four indicated it was an
aggressive cancer so it was one that
needed to be treated a lot a lot of
times today what they try to do is is
just watch and wait as much as possible
because they over treated for quite a
while but in my case it was clear that I
needed to get treatment I went to I
found a surgeon to do a robotic radical
robotic prostatectomy it's called The Da
Vinci surgery and was scheduled for
surgery and but beforehand he said to
get some scans done and one of the scans
showed that I was I was already in stage
four that the cancer had already
metastasized to my bones
so no surgery since then it's been treat
the systemic so it's two years since I'm
a diagnosis and this is that this riot
of cancer I have is called metastatic
castration resistant cancer which is
sort of a nasty term it just means that
the first the first treatment they give
you is hormones and the hormones are
meant to suppress testosterone so I have
the testosterone of a 66 year old woman
now but it's a very nasty form of cancer
and typically 24 to 30 months survival
time after you are diagnosed so that was
pretty sobering news how are you what
did what have you seen in yourself I
mean in our interactions at least via
email texts and so on and certainly even
speaking with you I mean you you seem
very upbeat and optimistic and very
engaged with Total Immersion for
instance what changes have you observed
in yourself just mentally or
psychologically since the diagnosis yeah
I you know I went through a
rollercoaster the first six to eight
months afterward where you know first I
felt sorry for myself and then the news
kept getting worse like I I didn't find
out that I had the worst variety of
prostate cancer right away it took a
while for the for the failure of my my
hormone treatment failed in two months
the cancer started growing again and
they usually look for two years so sick
of cancer suppression from that and you
know my oncologist said to be straight
with me on this talk and he said it's
the far side of bad news so you know I
was going through a rollercoaster where
the news kept getting more sobering and
I I was feeling anger anxiety not
depression ever never yeah never never
depression but but I felt quite a bit of
anxiety to the point where it you know
it be it was out of control and I I
sought treatment for anxiety
which I never thought I would ever need
in my life
so the first six to eight months were
like that but then with the help of the
anti-anxiety medication I'm on lexapro
and abilify and I don't mind I don't
mind admitting it it's worked it's
enabled me to reclaim who who I always
was which is a person who's driven by a
purpose and the purpose is to change
change the way people swim I mean
literally to change the way swimming is
taught and practiced in this world it's
I've always had such a powerful sense of
purpose and I wake up with that sense of
purpose every day and and I have to say
that in the past probably 16 months now
I haven't experienced any anxiety I
haven't experienced any depression I
wake up I still wake up every morning
fired up to do what I'm gonna do and
that day to which today is your podcast
and which which I couldn't be happier
about and I'm thrilled to have you on I
mean I wish we could spend some more
time together so I hope I'm een we we
had a chance I which was really exciting
for me after learning ti through the
book and seeing freeze frames of you
with all the diagrams showing correct
direction and so on to actually get in
the water in Hawaii with Sara and to
swim with you is just such a highlight
for me such such a wonderful experience
it was for me as well and I really feel
the need to say this but that I you know
knowing all you have on your plate and
especially in the midst of that TV
production and knowing what I know about
your your hunger to learn new things I
just had always assumed because you know
we were we were friends from a distance
and we met for Medford dinner in San
Francisco one time but you know we were
friends from a distance with periodic
contacts when when you wanted to make
another mention thank you of total
immersion in one of your books that when
I when I arrived in
Hawai I was so impressed as to see how
strong your hungers remained to improve
your swimming and I thought you know
it's not it's not a box II wanted to
check off at all he really cares about
this so I saw that and I was really
impressed and happy about that thank you
yeah it it's really been a foundational
skill for changing my life for the
better and furthermore I mean it's given
me this tool kit which is very clear
very counter intuitive but very clear
with which I've been able to take part
of course just drafting on what you're
doing but in say helping Sara and
watching that complete transformation
take place and helping some of my
friends who I've run into who say the
same thing that I said when I was say 25
they say I yeah I just don't swim no I'm
just not comfortable in the water and
usually what I'll say to that is well
why don't we just take an afternoon and
come with me to a pool or we'll just
find a lane that's 4 feet deep and let's
fix that
and they're like what what do you mean
fix it and it's and it's just the end
it's really just getting them to that
point that I experienced with total
immersion after the first day of
training which is oh my god I can
actually do this which is I mean similar
to the experience you had with the drill
you did with pressing down that you now
teaches torpedo where you realize oh my
god this story that I've been telling
myself my legs are heavy I'm just cursed
with heavy legs is completely a it's
either unfounded or completely fixable
right and what else what else am i
capable of changing about my swimming
and it's turned out there's nothing I
can't change yeah or your life right
yeah exactly if if this impossible is
not just possible right
like Tim Ferriss cannot swim is not only
possible to fix but in fact easy to fix
with the proper counterintuitive
teaching and progression in this cage
case which is Total Immersion I mean
it's it's such it's such a demonstration
it's such a profound demonstration of
possibility for me that I really
encourage anyone who is listening to
this and I'll say this also in the intro
who is unable to swim or views
themselves as being unable to swim or is
a poor swimmer to just try this because
it will open your eyes in such a way
that you not only look at swimming and
water differently but you will you will
look at other skills in your life
differently as well
I mean after total immersion that's when
I started asking myself what are the
other Impossibles what are the other
things I've told myself I just can't do
like play basketball or or shoot a
basketball was another one
let me reexamine that and then I found a
method that is sort of a corollary in a
sense to total immersion but for
basketball it turns out I think I might
beginning the name wrong but I think
it's Rick Torbett teaches basketball
shooting in a way that you would find
very much a close cousin to Ti and it
just makes sense and I was like okay Wow
okay that's two for two now what else is
there I thought the same thing when you
when you described your your first
tennis lesson
exactly oh yeah I read in Laura Lorenzo
same story yeah the way that he teaches
like okay this immediately makes sense
it is it is perfectly sensible and yet
I've never seen anyone teach this way
it's it's it's really a gift that you've
given and continue to give to the world
so all the crazy thing no one no one
else is still teaching this way you know
we've been doing it for 30 years with
incredible success and we're still he
only once teaching this way
why does that why is it what do you find
it's just a lot of a lot of built-in
resistance to change in the world as
well because there are in many many
places and you know they well they
believe what matters is how many laps
you do and how strong your pull and kick
is they persist in believing that and so
what is the first thing you learn when
when you take your beginners lesson is
how to kick and how to pull and that's
that's really putting the cart before
the horse if you're not comfortable in
the water oh yeah I mean that's just do
that'll just guarantee at least in my
case that you need to breathe ten times
more urgently you know crack the code so
to speak and and it works it just works
every single time well Terry what I want
to I want to make sure that we wrap up
in the next couple of minutes but what
would you like to share with with with
people who are listening in other words
you know if there were recommendations
you have certainly checking out Total
Immersion is a no-brainer as far as I'm
concerned and we can get to where they
can find more on that and so on in a
second but is there anything else you'd
like to convey anything you would
encourage people to to ask themselves or
suggest that they do since we have quite
a few people listening I am sure yes we
haven't we haven't gotten too much into
the how to maybe I can I can share a few
a few how-to suggestions that people can
try yeah let's do it and and some
principles I always like to go back to
first principles for as the basis for
anything that matters anything we care
about doing well and so I'll share five
first principles of intelligent
improvement oriented swimming
first is to recognize that as a human
swimmer you are an energy wasting
machine DARPA the Defense Advanced
Research Projects Agency in designing a
swim foil for the Navy SEALs back in
2005 they did a they did an efficiency
estimation for a group of lap swimmers
these these were not tutored or coach
swimmers but that people who think
they're pretty okay they swim laps a lot
and they found they were only three
percent efficient 97% of their energy
was going into something other than
locomotion so so as a human swimmer you
are naturally an energy wasting machine
and in everything you do focus on saving
energy before you focus on increasing
Fitness that goes back to what Bill
boomer said conditioning is something
that happens while you build refine her
imprint skills so that's principle
number one principle number two most of
what we know about swimming is wrong all
our primal instincts about swimming lead
us astray and most of what we hear are
not helpful so you have really have to
exercise critical thinking if someone
suggests you try something and it
doesn't seem to work well maybe maybe it
wasn't a good idea if they suggest you
try some want something or Tim asked you
to go to the pool with them in a 4-foot
shallow area and and you experience
something thereby that works then then
trust in your trust in your own
intuition about things and don't feel
that you have to believe what you hear
from authoritative sources principle
number three it's obvious that
efficiency is not natural for humans
inefficiencies is natural but is
entirely learn about as as Tim
discovered in a period of eight weeks
where he went from swimming 20 yards in
a pool and being exhausted to swimming a
mile in the in the ocean it's it's learn
about anyone and
one can learn to swim with great
efficiency and then improve on it
continuously by applying the principles
of mastery including love the plateau
principle number four if you want to
swim with more ease or more efficiency
think about what you can do to make your
vessel sleeker and I'll when I finish
with the five principles I'll just
mention three or four simple action
items that for the next time you go to
the pool but the strive for a sleeker
vessel it's it's a universally
unquestioned Truth among naval
architects and scientists who study fish
so why should it be different for your
body and then finally strive strive to
swim in a way that you you use your body
as a whole
resist any suggestion someone tells you
to just pull or kick or separate the
pull and kick into your training
strive for a seamlessly integrated
movement that is based in in the core so
those are five first printable
principles worth worth listening to
again in writing down I think and number
five but just before we get to the
action items just to give an example of
that integration that was one of these
aha moments that we've been talking
about for me at least was the idea that
that you not use your legs for
propulsion so if you don't think about
your legs and swimming as a propeller
but instead use a very small flick of
each leg to turn the hips and therefore
turn the shoulders so that you're going
from that fuselage right to fuselage
left and back and forth it changes the
entire nature of swimming right so that
was that was just one example of
integration that I found hugely helpful
it went at the tell flake illustrates
three other principles that I just
mentioned human swimmers are energy
wasting machines so what are you
focusing on with it with a toe flick
instead of leg
saving energy and principle number two
most of what we know about swimming is
wrong what did you know about swimming
before you learn TI what did you know
about the kick Helen votes had to use it
as a propeller to push me forward
alright and in principle number five a
principle number four strive for a
sleeker vessel so rather than focusing
on propulsion and a bigger bigger
stronger kick you lose used a smaller
lighter kick and it really worked
yeah that's why for the five principles
were illustrated by that that one thing
and you know the same thing with your
hand swapping you know you were what you
were accomplishing there was a pole that
was a little more patient a little
slower probably but but by you were
using your arms to reduce drag yep
definitely and it also it also helps
pull together the pieces in terms of
integrating your stroke just that timing
is is one of the things stopping the
kick which is interrupting your natural
rhythm but also having that timing in
your arms naturally promotes an
integrated us technique that where all
the parts are working together so what
what action items would you have for
people who want to try something at the
pool yeah so action item and I would
suggest that you don't swim long
distances while trying these if you can
swim anywhere from just about five
strokes to a half a lap and feel that
you're doing it that's that's good you
don't have to you don't have to leave
one end with it with a knob wheeling
that you're obligated to go to the other
end so the very first of these would be
hang or align your head most important
the thought the most fundamental thing
the first thing we always teach is hang
or align your head you could you could
visualize perhaps that there's a toe
line at
to the top of your head pulling your
spine directly forward while while you
you know while you do everything that
the stroking part of it that your spine
is always moving forward so get your
head aligned would be number one number
two use your arms to lengthen your body
not to push water back you're still
going to push water back but by using
your arms to lengthen your body you're
promoting two things a lower drag
profile and a complete movement you're
focused on completing the movement a lot
of people think about finishing the
stroke back by the hip finish it to the
front instead the third is the what what
Tim just mentioned which is you cannot
go wrong by kicking less just always
keep that in mind you cannot go wrong by
kicking last it's kicking is a great way
to burn energy and a great way to create
drag it's a very poor way to create
propulsion so those would be oh oh and
one more one more
anything you do more quietly is more
effective and efficient so whatever
you're doing it at a given moment in the
next lap strive to do it more quietly
and it will be better
so align your head lengthen your body
k-class swim more quietly for action
items yeah the the swimming quietly is
one that if I find myself getting
prematurely tired which I take is an
indication that I'm being inefficient
that's usually what I'll focus on I'll
stop I'll just rest at the side of the
pool for whether it is 30 seconds 60
seconds and then for the next handful of
laps just try to be as silent as
possible so no splashing with the feet
with the hands are really trying to
glide the arm in at an angle and to do
it as silently as possible is also one
of those exercises that just checks so
many different boxes it seems yeah
well Terry this is this has been great
I'm glad that we were able to find the
time to do this and of course people can
find Total Immersion online at Total
Immersion net where they can find videos
and instruction and everything else is
there anything that you would like
people to check out or any anywhere else
that people should say hello well first
of all I want to say thank you and I
want to say you are a masterful and
artful podcast host okay I'm working on
it working prices I think I felt very
well guided I would like to do a podcast
and I hope I hope to be a fraction as
good as you are when I when I do it so
well yeah I would like to offer all your
podcast listeners of seven day free
trial of our online swim Academy where
there's a tremendous amount of
information and you will have access to
every bit of it including straw
including streaming video and ebooks and
all kinds of information it's all free
everything we have produced is available
and all they have to do is go to Total
Immersion academy.com
forward slash Tim Total Immersion
academy.com forward slash Tim to learn
more and take advantage of that offer
perfect and everybody listening I'll
also put that in the show notes so if
you want to find links to that and
everything else we've talked about you
can find that at tim dot blog a forward
slash podcast and just search Terry's
name if you just search Terry's and see
I believe you are the only Terry I've
interviewed so far then you will pop
right up and Terry it's it's been such
an honor and a privilege to to have you
on and as far as your podcasting hosting
progress goes I think it's important to
if you want a good laugh listen to my
first episode that I did as a host
you'll realize just how much one can
improve yeah oh yeah
so not I think that if you use my first
episode as a as a hurdle I think that
you'll clear it with flying colors
you're already much better than I was
then
so don't be daunted by that and I hope
to hear your podcast soon myself but
Terry thank you so much for taking the
time I really really appreciate it
and and thank you so much for inviting
me it's a pleasure pleasure and a
privilege I've really looked forward to
and to everybody listening tryout Total
Immersion honestly whether you're a
swimmer or a non swimmer or someone
who's never quite been as comfortable as
you would like I I am NOT if you've seen
photos of me what you would think of as
built for swimming and I told myself all
sorts of handicapping stories and
accepted all types of partial
completeness until my 30s when I used
accountability by having a friend assign
me a new year's resolution I knew he
would bust my balls forever if I didn't
do it to get me to finally take it
seriously and taking it seriously meant
I took all sorts of classes and so on
and wasted a lot of time trying things
that were really really really hard like
kick boards and everything else doesn't
have to be hard and in fact good
instruction should seem very very clear
and it should make a lot of sense and
that's what I got from Total Immersion
and I can I can go down a long list of
my friends who have since learned how to
swim so definitely check it out and
Terry you mentioned it already but total
immersion academy.com forward-slash Tim
I really hope people give it a test and
share their experiences because it's it
can really be revelatory and to everyone
listening as always and until next time
thank you for tuning in
be safe out there question assumptions
and never stop learning okay guys that's
the end of the
first interview and from this point
forward you will hear several clips of
Terry's daughters Fiona
Carrie and Betsy interviewing him in the
hospital in the days before his passing
thanks for listening that's not written
down yet
so while you're talking about is what
makes Total Immersion distinctive yeah
yeah is teaching balance as the Keystone
skill of swimming no one else even
recognizes relevance as a skill okay let
alone the Keystone skill of swimming
efficiently no not just something
efficiently of being able to enjoy Swamy
being able swim with ease grace and
enjoyment and we we will approach it to
demonstrate that the total immersion way
is uniquely unique in promoting all
those ancillary benefits because we do
it consciously because we're trying to
develop the whole person not just the
swimmer yeah we're trying to grow the
whole person brain psyche and body your
approach is helping you right now like
the interval training sure everything
everything I've practiced and taught has
helped prepare me for this crisis moment
in my life okay can you give some
examples oh sure
your mindfulness yes process orientation
[Music]
like the way that you're drinking right
focus points focal points yes say what
your focus points for drinking are
that's what - my mindfulness I'm used to
doing things
guided by focal points an attentive to
focal points talk about your experience
with learning to drink but I have to
learn after my stroke I have to learn to
drink all over again and I'm applying
the same process to learn re teaching
myself how to drink that applied to
teaching myself how to breathe
seamlessly while swimming freestyle so
my focus points for drinking are sip
exhale relax swallow repeat and then
rest and roll and rest interval yes I do
exactly recognizing that what I'm doing
is treat training my brain because parts
of my brain have been injured parts of
my brain that controls swallowing
properly and not aspirating have been
injured and I have to train new neuron
just to take over that task the only way
to do it is with a conscious process all
right where I connect the motor and
cognitive neurons that are associated
with that activity what about the
emotional got the important points is
there an emotional aspects us to be
non-judgmental this experience making
mistakes is making mistakes is essential
to learning so that when I make a
mistake
I can recognize the mistake that I can I
can analyze the mistake I had the only
way to avoid it in the future is to
recognize it analyze it and then and
then come up with a strategy to avoid
aha right yeah how do you do that by
saying
recognizing that I have to exhale before
swallowing okay but what about the
emotional a specific law us yes dad
that's more technical though I mean like
fear anxiety anything like that do you
feel like your your practice almost in a
detached almost clinical place yeah in
doing this because my metaphor is you're
swimming right you're Singlish I know
English Channel you're swinging when I'm
happy
yeah right you're in rough water and
you're struggling recovering from a
stroke to recover from a stroke is like
training to swim around Manhattan so
when you enter rough water there's a lot
of turbulence around you which there
isn't it slower how would you compare
that to what's going on in your mind
when you're swimming in turbulent water
versus being rough for the water the
waters rougher the water or the more
turbulent my surroundings the khamar I
have to be external external turbulence
internal calm and there has to be the
more external turbulence I encounter the
more inner calm I must cultivate now I
think a very very important element in
this book is the fact that I'm writing
the entire book with stage-four cancer
yes and dealing with things like strokes
yeah as I'm as I'm writing the book yeah
that's gonna that's gonna be in the
intro yeah we want that to be prominent
yeah who wants we want readers and
potential readers to know this because
not everybody will have it over and read
and how do you feel like people can
apply that but how do you feel how do
you think that knowledge people can
apply that to themselves understanding
that it's not about ideal circumstance
it'll add an element of drama life drama
it'll add an element of life drama how
my different person writing this book
than the person that wrote the original
book this is a big this is a big part of
it how are you a different person well
I'm I'm 65 and 66 I was 45 then yeah
what are my life experiences that I'm
bringing to it this time stage four
cancer
yeah and this stuff that's come with it
and Dad I think it's also important to
know what is going on right now which is
very serious and they've told us is is
life-threatening but you you know you
said been saying this is not the end and
you're gonna get through this I have
many more healthy years good and that
like my my practice and work and
everything I've been teaching has helped
prepared me for this like almost nothing
else that I could have done yes what I'm
what I'm teaching you in this book now
can i interject some things we talked
about this yesterday you have
significant brain swelling and we were
talking about visualizing you said
visualizing a skinny brain which was a
joke but really the idea of visual
meditating and visualizing on your
brains well decreasing talk about that
have you have you been doing that the
physical process by which that happens I
needed to understand the physical
process by which that happens in order
to be able to visualize it Helen Helen
McHugh helped also Helen's been very
very helpful here in my conversation
with the various physicians who come
through she came I'm not sure she did
shake shake she said and she's very very
good at that okay let me just finish
this thought can you describe your bit
of any visualization technique that you
have used since you've been here
sure I can okay which is staying same
blood flow through my brain and and
excess excess moisture and my brain
tissues being drawn into the bloodstream
and carried out of the brain to be
excreted and how often have you been
doing the visualization once a day twice
a day Oh on and off not on a schedule
never you have a quiet moment yeah what
about the value of rest a lot of times I
don't know I haven't thought about it
well remember when you they tell me the
most important element in my recovery is
rest absolutely yeah they the doctors
here so I see a connecting thread with
that and your other yeah you know the
injuries that you had during the year
that you broke all those records dad
yeah I remember how you weren't able to
train as much all right that's good
quest that's a good point dad could you
talk towards the phone because I it's
the microphones over here all right that
was in for stress that year and for
stress actually enabled you right in for
stressed making sure what do you mean
meaning you see we can see improvement
yes
of what sort you can speak ranks now the
first day we could barely wake you right
so you needed to rest yeah so there's a
connection there and my body needed to
rest the first day force trusted it was
it had undergone a lot of stress on
Tuesday yeah so so it was recovering on
Wednesday okay so the importance of rest
and recovery in some practice from the
stress of the stroke Tuesday